I don't know.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the final sentences of surah chapter
number 73 the end of verse number 20
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
He says, "Subhan,
hence recite of the Quran what is
convenient."
What is made convenient and easy for
you. We mention that this command of
recitation means one of two things.
Correct? It means one of two things.
When Allah says
recite,
he is commanding one of two things. What
are those two things?
The first one is
prayer.
Meaning stand in prayer inj at night
based on what is convenient what is
possible for you giving the
circumstances of that night or that day
or the following day or that night if a
person is traveling if a person is ill
if a person is in jihad if a person
is etc. So it may fluctuate. So he
mentions recite meaning pray. The second
meaning of recite recitation here means
what? First one is prayer. The second
one is
what's that? Quran meaning recite in
salah
and that is what is the least
permissible or the least valid
recitation of the Quran and salah
fat. The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
said
He says, "Whoever
performs a prayer and does not recite
in this prayer then his prayer is
meaning his prayer is incomplete
and this means invalid. This is the bare
minimum of recitation
and this is why fat is the way it is and
it's placed in the mus the way it is and
was revealed more than one time to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. It was
revealed both in Mecca and Medina.
Right? So the statement of Allah,
recite
what is convenient for you, what is easy
for you of the Quran. Two opinions, two
meanings. The first meaning is what is
intended by recitation here is what?
Salah. And what is intended by
recitation is recitation in salah. Very
good. We understand
now if we say what is intended as salah
jump from
recite to pray
that is that as we've mentioned before
it is common
common
u it is a common
way of speaking
that you mention in something refer to
something by its most critical parts,
right? if we if I wanted to refer
to a car,
what could I call it?
Could call what's a part of a car that
is integral?
Wheels, right? That's not only integral,
that's the whole point of the car. If
the car was really really really perfect
in every way but it didn't have wheels
it is useless. Correct? Therefore that's
the essence of the car. Everything else
is just busy work. So or everything else
is designed around that function of
wheels of transportation.
So an an example of that is referring
to the hole by one of its integral or
most prominent parts. Also for instance,
if a person wanted to refer to a gun,
they could refer to it as a what?
Huh?
[Arabic recitation]
fire. It is called that. Actually, there
are dozens of references to a pistol.
Just a sword, these are iconic
things part of human culture, right?
What about if you called it a pipe?
That's correct, right? Its most critical
component is its barrel, right? Just
wheels on a car. Or if you refer to
a home or a house by how many bedrooms
are in it. You got a two-bedroom, a
threebedroom. Does that mean it has no
kitchen? It has no living room, it has
no front door, it has no it's just
bedrooms. No. But that is the point of
what? Of a home to facilitate your rest
in safety and in safety and shelter.
So when Allah refers to salah as
recitation,
this happens in the Quran. He refers to
salah as in the Quran. He refers to
salah as
in in the Quran. Correct? He refers to
or in the Quran. All of these are
references to salah because these are
integral components of it and this is
the point of the prayer. So
multiple places in the Quran Allah
refers to salah as recitation.
He says
the recitation of
we know that our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam explained this verse that the
recitation of fud is most witnessed.
Meaning the angels on the morning and
night shift.
The angels of the day come down. The
angels of the night get ready to go up
to to clock out right to go for their
and at that moment at that's when all of
them are present. And so Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
and specifically what part of
which part of that is most stressed
Quran right that's why the longest
recitation of all the prayers is and
right the longest recorded is and those
two are usually
The longest he says
establish prayer
establish
establish.
He didn't say pray even though it's a
shorter sentence. He could have said
and pray.
But that's not what's intended, is it?
What's intended is not just the
performance of prayer. What is intended
is the
[Arabic recitation]
you, Mr. Engineer. The establishment of
prayer. That's what's intended. It's not
good enough just to pray. It's not good
enough. Establishment of prayer.
Establishment mean that all of its all
of its prerequisites, its conditions,
its pillars, its obligations are met to
a tea.
I have a question. How many conditions
are there for prayer?
Yeah. Yeah.
Eight.
There's at least five. Yeah.
Good. I mean, you're one shy. It's nine.
Nine conditions. How many pillars?
14. How many obligations?
Yellow, say it.
You got it right the first time. Say
that. Now's your Now's your time to
shine. Eight. Come on, man.
Nine conditions, 14 pillars, eight
obligations, and almost countless sunn.
Do we know them all? This is critical
when Allah says establish prayer. We all
just prayed here. How many of us can be
certain based on evidence?
Not speaking about what dad taught me.
Not speaking about what I saw people do.
I'm speaking about evidence. Allah said,
his messenger said that our prayer is
eligible for acceptance.
Because in order for our prayer to be
eligible for acceptance,
it has to meet its conditions, its
pillars, its obligations. If we don't
know them, then we have no idea what
we've just done, do we?
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
was sitting in the masid.
A man walked in.
His name was Ibuk.
And Abu was there
and you know it's a big masid. As he
walked in he saw the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam there
and he said assalamu alaykum
and he saidum and then he prayed.
Then he went
to the prophet sallall.aii
am he he approached him and he said
he said
go back and pray because you didn't pray
yet
linguistically he just prayed right
but legislatively meaning did he just
pray let me ask you a question if
someone were to Make salah without wudoo
knowingly. No, no, no. Just stand and
make salah.
We all saw him make salah.
We could say he prayed, right?
But in Islam,
as far as
the legislation of Islam is concerned,
did he pray?
He did not pray.
He did not pray. Why? Because his prayer
is invalid out the gates. He didn't
pray. He did not pray because he's
missing a critical component.
Just in all actions,
if a person stands for
but they worship other than Allah,
did they make salah?
Did they give zakah? Did they fast? No.
Why? We saw them do it. But in Allah's
book, did they do any of those things?
Why? Because it's invalid. Right? The
prerequisite of all actions being
accepted are two conditions. What are
the two conditions?
No. not any good deed.
What is the prerequisite? the condition
of any good deed being accepted by
Allah,
right? So, sincerity. What's the other
one?
So, what do we call that?
Mutaba, right? We call it Mutaba.
Meaning that it's not an innovation.
We all know this.
Because in order for us to become
Muslim, we have to say whatahill
that's sincerity, right?
What is that?
That it has to be only for Allah and it
has to be in accordance with the will of
Allah. That's the condition.
Let's say a person worships Asian.
They believe that he is the son. He is
one of three. They believe in the
trinity. But they also believe that
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah. So
they pray and fast Ramadan and give zaka
and they go to Hajj and they cry and
they and they love and they go to jihad
and they they are martyed. Their very
soul they gave it for the sake of Allah.
Did they really do any of those things
on the day of judgment?
We understand that, right?
[Arabic recitation]
condition.
The condition has to be met in order for
the thing to be valid. If a person knows
that this is the direction of the and
they face that direction, they turn
their back to it and make salah. It's a
really good salah. It's a fantastic
salah. A touching salah. Anyone walked
in and saw that man praying, it would
touch their heart.
Cried beautiful recitation, perfect
form, perfect everything. But he's
facing away from the knowingly. Did he
pray?
So this man approached the prophet and
said,
he said,
"Said go back and pray. you haven't
prayed yet. So he went back and he
prayed. Then he came back and again
he saidum
go back and pray for you haven't prayed
yet.
So the man went back and prayed again.
Then he came back. He said he said
go back and pray. You haven't prayed
yet. This is how many times? Three
times.
Let's say this wasn't the messenger of
Allah. Let's say this was a scholar, a
teacher. Okay?
And
this is your interaction with him. Most
people, what would they do?
What kind of imam is this? He's not
nice. He's a bad imam. He didn't service
me properly. I am an unhappy customer.
I'm unsatisfied with this customer
service cuz the imam, the teacher, the
scholar, he's here to serve me. I am the
customer. You made me feel bad.
How can you learn anything when this is
the approach,
right?
If we don't trust our teachers, there's
no point to this. There's no point to
this dynamic here at all. This is
nothing more than entertainment. if we
don't take it seriously and if we don't
trust our teachers.
He's doing that because he doesn't like
me. I know he doesn't me. I saw it
in his eyes before. Right? Because we
have such ignorance, we can't even
separate and distinguish between the
whispers of El and our own thoughts.
And so everything that pops into our
head, it must be true. It's correct.
It's definitely true. Can't possibly see
it from any other angle.
So when he came back the third time,
he said, he said,
he said,
he said, I swear by the one who has sent
you with the truth. this is the best I
know how to do, so please teach me.
Now, why that process? Why didn't he
just teach him immediately as soon as he
saw what was wrong?
We'll see that the reason his was
invalid is because it was rushed.
There was noina.
There was no tranquility. Tranquility in
salah is a pillar of salah.
At every junction, at every stage, at
every place of prayer, at every
position, you or I assume in prayer, we
have to reach a level of what is
referred to as tranquility.
Nina,
if we don't, the prayer is invalid.
this man in what what's his main flaw
here? He's in a
[Arabic recitation]
companions praying that? did
he did he learn that prayer from Abu
Bakr and Omar and Ali and Abu and Anb
Malik and Albb andb
and Zade?
Did he learn that from
usb and zbin?
No, he didn't learn that from them. He
saw people doing that. He did it. Hey,
it's good enough, right? I got stuff to
do, places to be. He's in a hurry. He
didn't bother to investigate any
further. And we said that the highest
skill of a teacher is to first plant a
seed of what in the student?
Curiosity.
If you cannot get your student to be
curious, you're wasting your time. You
must might as well be talking to this
wall right here.
That is half of the fen of teaching.
Half of the skill of teaching is
planting a seed of curiosity in the
listener. If it was one of those other
companions, he would have probably just
told him immediately, "That's wrong.
Don't do it again." This man's in a
hurry and he's been around the Muslim
and still hasn't gotten the message.
Therefore,
we need to break through that
stubbornness.
We need to break through that
hurriedness. Hur hurriedness, if that's
a word, that that huriness, right?
to get that seed of curiosity planted to
where he's now asking and slowing down
enough to say I I've thought about it
and I'm not sure what I'm doing wrong so
please teach me at that moment he
immediately taught him he said if you
wish to stand for prayer then make then
face the and say Allahbar
and then recite of the Quran what is it
what you are able to and then say Allah
and fall into remain in rur until you
reach a degree of tranquility.
Tranquility is gauged
by every bone and muscle in the body
reaches a point of rest and nonmovement.
This is the level. This is what's
referred to asina.
We say what's the bare minimum of nina
in prayer? It is that the body entirely
ceases movement
in that position.
So you make
the entire body all the bones the joints
the muscles have to relax and stop and
pause in that position entirely.
Some of the scholars gauge that by at
least saying
three times
or subh
or
in the sitting between the two ses
etc. The point is he taught him. Now
this man had been praying a lot but he
actually hadn't prayed and that's the
meaning of the statement of Allah.
Could you imagine the nightmare
scenario?
[Arabic recitation]
day of judgment what they have done of
deeds and turn it into scattered dust in
the wind." It's not even dust. It's
smaller than dust. To Allah, it's
smaller than dust. You know what Alhaba
is in the Arabic language?
You ever you ever sit in the window,
the sun is coming through and you look
at the the the light and you see
those little floaters floating around
that little dust that's it's almost too
light for gravity to grab it. That's
not even dust. Dust once the wind
settles, it settles. Heat never settles.
It's nothing. It's not even visible to
the naked eye. That's how insignificant
all of their tears and blood and sweat
are because they didn't bother
themselves to to think about what Allah
wants from them. It's just this is what
I have to offer. So, he's going to just
have to accept it. That arrogance
immediately
invalidates
worship immediately. nightmare scenario
being resurrected. Alhamdulillah got
great. You have these mountains of
deeds.
Nothing.
Nothing. And hopelessness.
The gates of hell are now open. Once you
pass through those gates, there is
nothing. No other. You will never ever
see the outside of those gates again.
We only get one shot at this.
We have to try our best.
and
subhanahu